so let's do some more NSA stuff because
this broke this week and it gets to what
these guys are saying earlier that we
keep hearing so much about this stuff
but now we're just forgetting it the
second that it happens so NBC News
obtained NSA documents that were taken
by Snowden that revealed that the
British government is able to tap into
the actual fiber cables so that they can
see what people are doing on Facebook
and on YouTube and pretty much whatever
you're doing online the monitoring
program is called squeaky dolphin the
documents leaked by former NSA employee
Edward Snowden and obtained by NBC News
include a top-secret presentation of a
pilot program given to American
intelligence officials by GCHQ the
British equivalent of the NSA the slide
show how British spies are capable of
tapping into fiber-optic cables and
pulling unencrypted high-speed data
including YouTube addresses they analyze
the information to answer critical
questions none of the data is gathered
within the u.s. sources say but
Americans who use these websites
overseas may have their online activity
monitored the NSA says they operate
within the law and do not spy on the
social media activities of ordinary
Americans
well if sources say that they don't spy
and the NSA says they're not doing it
then I'm sure they're not of course
Google and Facebook say they knew
nothing about this and then the NSA
actually did release a statement the NSA
is not interested in the communications
of people who are not valid foreign
intelligence targets any implication
that the NSA's foreign intelligence
collection is focused on the social
media communications of everyday
Americans is not true we collect only
those communications that we are
authorized by law to collect for valid
foreign intelligence and
counterintelligence purposes regardless
of the technical means used by the
targets now of course they're gonna say
that and I'm gonna even gonna grant them
a little bit of maybe that's true but
isn't there really no way they would
know that that's true because anybody
that's looking at the information could
do whatever they want this thing is sort
of like Snowden right yeah this sort of
saying is we don't go through the
internet to get regular everyday
Americans conversations we do that
through the phone tap
we have two different arms that it
reached the different things so we don't
worry about them we have that covered
somewhere else yeah that's where that's
when they release statements like this
how do you possibly take them to be a
true or a fact I basically figure in 15
years someone's gonna write the tell-all
that basically describes how that was a
total lie yeah I call me paranoid but
that's sort of that what it's gotten to
at this point I kind of feel like so I
you know luckily no one is watching this
on you - oh not this sigh um but if you
are watching please click the ad that'll
help so one of the things that I thought
was really interesting about this is
that the NSA and the GCHQ they say it's
important so they can monitor trends in
case of riots or uprisings or things
like that so here in America where we
have freedom of speech isn't this the
scariest possible thing that they could
be monitoring us for pre riots you know
you mean that before we even have a
chance that they could be cutting us off
that it's and what rights will become
then as protests you know I maybe some
some kind of rules are we with only Adam
do we had a denim getting the name of
the walk even before these things get
started there now they can they
collectively call everything a riot or
uprising all those movies so anything
you say becomes that level and they
concur as we know how they call a lot of
people were involved in it look at these
up right they're trying to get against
the society against our government our
way of life and but then if it's on the
other side it goes straight to it well
you know it's the who's a terrorist and
who's a freedom fighter has always been
in the eye of the beholder unfortunately
you know and I think that it becomes
very easy to sort of oh no we're only
doing that for these people but no
that's where your over here you know and
that's where it just gets a little
cranky from so taking it from the
reverse of the people that say I'm doing
nothing wrong how do we some what people
that are aware that this stuff's going
on and acknowledge it how do we not go
down the rabbit hole of paranoia with it
because I don't think necessarily the
entire system is built by people that
are actually trying to do damage I think
a lot of them are trying to do good but
of course that can be used in awful ease
but how do we not be paranoid about
and think that your webcams not looking
at you all the time or any of that kind
of stuff as you know and I hate that I
think to a certain extent you have to go
I mean not because I think we should but
there's gonna be comes report we have to
say well I'm not doing anything because
we can't do much about everything we can
do something to a certain extent so
there comes a point where you go okay
fine they know that I watch this video
okay if the target can't keep our credit
card information secret
I don't trust YouTube and whoever else
is gonna keep all of our other data you
know secure either yeah I just again
this is where you get into that
resignation of well this is what happens
now that we're on the internet and we're
on we are vulnerable to having our our
cookies examined you know I think at
some point you either devote your life
to sort of trying to you know fight back
against the sort of thing or you sort of
yeah I don't know I feel like I've done
to them I shrug my shoulders like well
this is this is the world we live in now
what are we gonna do about it well what
are we gonna do that so I watched the
movie Network you gave me the cue a
moment ago the movie network I believe
it was 1977 did it win the Oscar for
Best Picture no loss to Rocky
it lost to Rocky in Star Wars I think
was also up that your fault that was
following your okay I'm close but I
watch the movie network you guys must
watch this movie 1977 all about you know
a corporation and media and [ __ ] and
all the things that we talk about here
all the time are we ever gonna have the
Howard Beale moment because the iconic
moment from the movie is when he's you
know he's doing a news piece and he gets
up and he says I'm mad as hell and I'm
not gonna take it anymore and that's
sort of what we're the movie jumps off
from oh is there anything that could
happen that would cause Americans to
have that moment do I mean do we need a
public figure do we need a news person
or a politician somebody to really thing
is Howard Beale is insane and what
happens is that the network exploits
that for ratings right now so I think
one could argue that that already
happened I think everything in network
has pretty much already happened at this
point that's the scary thing about it
that movie was satire in 1976 and now
you look at it like well they saw that
coming you know I may be Paddy Chayefsky
totally read the writing on the wall and
so yeah now you have
this corporate driven media you have
news as entertainment you have an agenda
that comes through based on who's buying
the ads and and you know it's it is it's
terrifying but here we are so who can
save us anyone save us we need a neo to
break through the matrix if it happens
and I go back to the a little of the
Justin Bieber and Andrew Mitchell if she
got the the the the message in her ear
we have to adjust and be punished
because we have breaking news you know
we're not going if she did it that means
a lot of people would support her but
then it would go away
she whatever would happen does she of
course you would get fired over
something like that but if it's someone
that's not that's lower profile okay get
out of here you're not following what we
need to do here you're killing us and
stables you get pushed aside and don't
think about them anymore so how if it
does happen we have this thing where we
work collectively we say you're being
crazy you said I got a snap on TV on
every on every website you'd see seeing
seeing an anchor flip loses his mind
flips out runs off camera he must have
lost his [ __ ] yeah and we read him off
as crazy you know it's funny every time
I'm watching Wolf Blitzer that's what I
think when this guy is such a freakin
robot and an emotion the guy couldn't
improv his way out of a wet paper bag
and it's like he's the one I think that
if he had a human moment maybe could get
people to wake up but I give CNN Farhad
man I'm pretty much the only one
watching